what is visible that should not be
visible me hahahaha self-loathing joke
hi my name is grace Helbig do not know
now you know your life is different now
I have a friend that has a birthday
coming up and so I wanted to make him a
cake but he does not like sweet things
very much
he does like however I went online and I
found a recipe for a flamin hot cheetos
cheese and that's what we're gonna
attempt to make today today originality
is just like the sanctity of our
American government it's dead
that's follow a recipe I got recipe from
tastemade calm it's a great recipe you
can make the people that don't have
sweet tooth's or that smoke weed or that
well we are things first weight to make
sure our microphone is on create the
oven to 300 degrees did it Wow I feel so
accomplished already Oh Andy graham
cracker crumbs no bread wrappers
wouldn't go in the refrigerator low-fat
graham crackers and whatever we need one
and a half cups of graham crap graham
crap crumbs yep need one and a half cups
of graham cracker crumbs so we're just
gonna I don't know how much one I have
subsist like on Trump doesn't know what
being irrational reason a little dunya
yeah good it's not funny anymore it's
actually a nightmare
that's America right there okay for
those of you that are learning about
American government here's just a quick
visual presentation of how it's running
at the current moment I have a food
processor what am i doing in America it
also need six tablespoons of melted
butter this is butter
that's a microwave you do the math
AMERICA AMERICA AMERICA AMERICA AMERICA
AMERICA
something smells like burning the
government
everything's fine not a nuclear war yet
Jesus welcomed optimistic Fridays with
grace Helbig subscribe to my channel for
more uplifting moments like this did
this melt they think I'm supposed to use
butter and not I can't believe it's not
butter which is the opposite of what
this is to use let's see if I butter
because I'm an idiot
isn't this amazing I have exactly 6
tablespoons of actual butter in my
refrigerator ready to go
oh hey weird clump of weird actually one
of my morning affirmations that I look
at mere one cup oh we did this perfect
one and a half cups everything's coming
up Gracie Cup
yeah at the butter then we're adding two
tablespoons of this stuff it's called
Tajin it's a Mexican spice I don't have
time to explain what it is wait is it
because this is gonna get weird hot on
the groan tastemade said that this
balances out the flavors of the flamin
hot cheetos in the crust etc etc it's oh
my god two tablespoons of sugar
why two and then we mix it right right
right mix this all together until it
looks like sand mix it all together till
it looks like Donald Trump's face before
he exfoliates no that's mean and we're
gonna take a springform pan I don't know
this was in Target and I got it we're
gonna press this into a lightly greased
springform pan this is how my mom
greases thing take a paper towel put
some butter I can't believe it's not
butter and then just sort of mash it
around okay now we press this in get in
there crust
wait artist smells actually pretty
decent it's an impression of what no
one's ever said to me
push this in don't let your eyes fool
you this is not a Donald and Melania sex
tape so you want to go up the sides a
little bit and we put it in the oven to
bake for 13 minutes let's do it be right
back
well what do we do only way
thank God let's take our crust on the
oven whoa that seems like a crush
now wait to let this cool completely
which means we have to let it sit for
longer than I want to because I'm
impatient put this to the side and let
this sit while we make our filling our
supposed to mix our filling in a normal
mixer which I don't have but I have a
nutribullet not spawn three packages of
cream cheese other thing this is not the
right way to do this but hey perfect
shove it in there brave Jesus in a
tablespoon of cornstarch two teaspoons
of lime zest one cup of sugar
look who pre measured and look who has
no more space left okay I should
probably just mix this in an actual Bowl
I think up ahead let's see let's see if
we can mix it a little bit and then add
more to it the absolute wrong choice
let's just pan mix it in a bowl
get out cream cheese organic shake wait
hey there they are
the rest of the sugar goes in let's
whisk until creamy oh my god I have
become a stand mixer Hey calm the cave
people made cakes for their friends now
we had half a cup of lime juice
I don't know how much that was you hear
that ASMR man we had three eggs not six
three oh my god you're back in the game
ah okay I think we have our cheesecake
batter crust is cooled enough we're
gonna pour this into our graham cracker
crust okay then we put this back in the
oven at 300 degrees for 60 minutes home
good luck please ah thank God let's pull
our cheesecake out look it looks like a
cheesecake now we're supposed to let it
cool for forever before we add our
flamin hot cheeto toppings I'll see you
in the decorations are happening
cheesecake is somewhat cold so now it's
time to add the flaming hot cheetos
let's do it
two cups of crushed flamin hot cheetos
oh now we just evenly push it out so
basically we're done we've pushed our
flamin hot cheetos into our cheesecake
now we're supposed to put it in the
refrigerator to let it finish cooling
before we pop open the springform pan
because that's how these things work
I've googled it we'll be back in a
little bit with an actual authentic
taste test once it's completely cool how
about that haha okay yes this is the
whole point of this whole end of this
video is to figure out if this lemon hot
cheetos cheesecake is okay okay with a
plastic no this is real this is the real
deal so this one has Donatello and
Michelangelo okay there you go come to
bite I'm like that looks really good I
don't know about this looks really good
all right sorry my nice thing sorry to
hear a gastrointestinal system it's
really good really genuinely really good
feel like it's probably weird to be
honest is the Cheesecake then get out of
those those are just for decoration it's
like you don't eat the balloon I know
but you eat the balloon if the balloon
is edible
oh man it's everywhere good not bad
right
no it's not bad it's like key lime pie
with afterburners yeah they're gonna
down stratus the spoiler on the back of
it there's nothing wrong with that if
you want to watch more videos like this
Dean Ambrose won't be here every time so
make sure that you check it out now
while you can I make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday sometimes I'm
mostly not I don't know give you a
purple
that's what an adult man like subscribe
his channel so I get more presents like
those things it's a toy for her so mine